hi everyone welcome to our homeroom live
stream really excited about the
conversation we're going to have in a in
a few minutes with eduardo setlin from
the amgen foundation i encourage any of
y'all who have questions start putting
them in the message board on youtube and
on facebook if you have questions about
science education the work of corporate
philanthropy
even the biotech industry careers and in
science or careers in philanthropy but
before we get to that i will make a few
of my standard announcements first of
all a reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization we can only
exist through donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about going to khan
academy.org
donate and donations of all size
make a very very big difference i also
want to give a special shout out to
several organizations that have stepped
up especially as we entered into the
covid period we were already running at
a deficit pre-covered and then you could
imagine our server costs are two to
three x of normal we are see we're
trying to accelerate a whole series of
content and programmatic efforts to
support parents teachers and students
through the crisis special thanks to
google.org att fastly bank from america
and novartis and also a very special
thanks uh to the amgen foundation that
has been working with us for many years
now we're going to talk a little bit
more in depth about it with eduardo
helping us bring great science content
to millions of students around the world
and obviously that was very relevant
pre-covet and it's even more relevant as
you can imagine as folks are even more
dependent on this type of content before
we get to that conversation i'm also
going to bring in my colleague dan who
has a few
announcements i think sal um so we're
wanting to announce a couple of webinars
that we have this week the first one is
today and it's targeted for teachers
jeremy shiffling who's our teacher guru
is going to be walking through a demo of
the classroom experience from a student
perspective for teachers
in order to build an understanding of
the student experiences by going through
several processes including how to
register what assignments look like when
they receive them and how to try out a
course mastery goal and that is
scheduled for today at 4 p.m pacific
time 7 pm eastern time and the second
webinar is tomorrow and that one's
targeted for parents of young learners
ages two through seven and that one's
titled how to keep your child learning
and happy at home and that one is going
to be led by renee scott who's the
director for early education for
education partners at stanford and um
caroline who flexor who's the ceo and
co-founder of khan academy kids and
they'll be sharing some they'll be
discussing some easy ways to boost
learning throughout the day at home for
young learners and that one is tomorrow
at
um tomorrow at 4 p.m pacific time and 7
p.m eastern and both webinars will be
recorded and available online we'll post
those a little bit afterwards as all of
our webinars are
back to you sal
great thanks thanks so much dan well uh
with that and i encourage folks to check
that out we're going to be having even
more webinars and programs to support
folks through this very um difficult
back to school period
but i'm excited to introduce our guest
eduardo setlin head of the amgen
foundation and i'd also like to consider
him as something of a friend eduardo
uh thanks for joining us
hi sal hi everyone it is a privilege and
an honor to be with you today thanks for
having me
no no our honor so maybe a good place to
start i'm sure a lot of folks have heard
of amgen but we have a lot of young
people who maybe know okay they do
something in biotech or something in
pharma what do they do and what does the
foundation do so maybe that's that's a
good place to start
sure
so uh the md foundation is the
philanthropic arm of amgen we are a
medical biotechnology
firm we are we just turned 40 this year
about
40 miles northwest of los angeles and we
are a large independent medical
biotechnology company with a very
powerful but simple
mission
which is to serve patients
the core reason our company exists is to
make the most of scientific discovery of
scientific developments to help patients
fighting very serious illnesses through
the amgen foundation
we have the mission of inspiring the
next generation of innovators the next
generation of scientists as well as
investing in scientific literacy as you
think about what is the key input to
what amgen does as a company it is human
talent we are firm believers in the
power of uh each one to really bring
their very best in the capacity to have
an impact in the philanthropic
investments we make our focus uh in that
space
and and focusing on that on the
foundation element of it you know where
where do you all try to focus as you try
to build a pipeline of folks who can go
into science who can contribute to
science who develop a love for science
as i just mentioned we've been long-time
partners and that partnerships has only
been growing but what are the types of
projects that you try to invest in and
how do you know if they're working
sure so you know
when you think about the philanthropic
space
there are millions of amazing
organizations doing very good work
throughout the country throughout the
world folks who are really putting all
their energy towards improving the human
condition
we took a very focused approach
uh by inspiring the next generation of
scientists and uh uh
uh an external science sorry in uh
scientific literacy so we started on a
journey
where
it was really all about how do we create
unique learning opportunities for
students how do we level the playing
field so that every student has access
to that kind of learning that will
really trigger in their mind hey
maybe there's something here for me
maybe i could be a scientist or
maybe not but i know enough about the
scientific method to navigate the
challenge of the modern world
we take an approach to be focused for
the long term
to uh really be driven by results
and for a very long time we have two
main programs something called engine
scholars and something called amdromatic
experience let me touch on the two to
get to this moment where we're living
now and how
our work has evolved to hampton scholars
we invest today 24 different uh
universities that host uh 15 students
each summer for an intense summer
research experience the idea is that
these students are having the
opportunity to live the life of a
scientist
for an entire summer
each of the universities
oversees their own
application process we'd encourage
undergraduate students from around the
world to apply to this program
and we provide the financial resources
for them to get to one of these
universities and we also do annual
symposia that brings the students
together tell you more about how we're
dealing with that in the world of covid
in a second
and then the separate program is
something called amg biotech experience
which started 30 years ago right here in
the thousand oaks neighborhood where we
are in southern california
where a local hampton scientist
partnered with a biology teacher to say
how can we leverage some of the
techniques that we do in our company to
help students see themselves in the role
of that scientist
so that program provides the curriculum
it provides professional grade equipment
and it provides ongoing support and
training for teachers
to provide these opportunities for
students and throughout this two to
three week curriculum
the students have the opportunity to
transform a bacterial cell into a
protein factory we use uh a a red
fluorescent protein which can be seen
with with the naked eye so it's really
applying some of the same mechanisms
that our company used to make medicines
such as erythropoietin
and other biopharmaceutical companies
used to make
medicines like insulin but putting it in
the hands of students so that they can
live the life of a scientist
this program saw it took us about 15
years to get to 50 000 students
primarily in the united states today
we're reaching 90 000 students all over
the world on an annual basis we have uh
1500 teachers engaged in the in the
initiative and they are the ones who
really create this transformative moment
within their classrooms leveraging the
curriculum and creating
a unique opportunity for their students
for a very long time those programs were
the core of what we did the challenge
with those programs was how do we scale
up
and increase our reach we're very proud
again to go from 50 000 over 15 years to
90 000 a year
but the question of
a
significantly large growth it would not
be possible to do so with a hands-on
platform and uh
that's what triggered our early
conversations with you back in 2015.
now and if i were to read between the
lines of everything all of the amazing
work that y'all have been doing it
sounds like there's a pattern that
maybe a lot of students don't even
though they might be interested in
science i mean i argue how can you not
be interested in science it's trying to
explain the universe that we're in and
pretty much everything that we have at
our disposals that does that defines
modern civilization is based on science
uh but it sounds like you know a lot of
kids for whatever reason they watch
movies or their stereotypes that develop
where they say oh well those scientists
look different than me maybe i'm not
meant to be a scientist and you all are
doing a really amazing work that kids
actually say realize that no you are
going to be you can be a scientist and
actually it's especially important if
you don't look like some of the people
you might see in on the tv screen that
you go into science because you might be
able to bring a unique perspective and a
unique creativity to it and then if i'm
hearing another dimension is how do you
give access to really cutting edge work
because sometimes the science that you
do in in school can be a little bit more
let's call it old school and kids might
have trouble connecting that to you know
the modern frontiers of what might go on
in the labs at amgen which is which is
powerful and obviously our work with
y'all is how do we scale that even
further how do we get even more kids
comfortable and and uh
feel like they deeply understand science
yes absolutely it's it's a multi-pronged
issue i think there is
um the the challenge of the stereotypes
the the the question of who can become a
scientist
uh but also the sense that you can't be
what you can't see even the
possibilities of how do we bring that
closer to students to see hey maybe this
could be me um i add to that the
complexity of you know the educational
system in a lot of ways i was rereading
your book recently silent in the in the
final chapters the the analysis of you
know
if our student if you think about the
way the classroom learning is typically
organized in a pre-covered world and now
you know i'll talk about my little girl
uh who's eight now when she went from uh
preschool to kindergarten she went from
an environment where she could move
around she could decide on what she was
going to play with
to an environment on a traditional
school where all the desks were
organized you know cemetery style and
she was expected to be quiet and pay
attention and absorb the content and
then you know that was the given and
i i think that when you fast forward and
compound that not only into the
elementary middle high school and
sometimes even at the university level
with the lecture driven uh lessons
you lose a lot of the power to engage
the students uh one of my favorite books
got most likely to succeed they talk
about in their educational system was
going to teach students how to ride a
bike you would spend a couple of weeks
on the history of the bicycle then you
know we would talk about all the
different parts
of the bicycle if you're going to a very
good school we'll talk about the physics
of balance and then um at the end of it
we would give you a test with a lot of
you know hard questions and you know
independently if you're doing really
well or just okay there's this
expectation that you leave the school
and you're able to ride your bike
not only far less exhilarating but not
like the real practice of the skill
so
we think about programs like scholars
and amgen biotech experience in allowing
the students to see
really what the scientific process is
all about we did a research we did some
research with high school students
primarily the united states but
replicated it across the world
and students love science they really
struggle with the science class
and the way the science is taught and
you know people can you can go at this
in many different ways uh but we see
actually that science teachers are the
biggest ally we have they are enormously
committed to providing the best possible
education for their students but they
need the tools they need the assistance
and they need the resources to create
those kinds of opportunities for those
students we have a question here related
to that from facebook lynn bradley a 6th
grade science teacher asks she teaches
at a title 1 school most kids don't have
supplies for experiments at home
curious about ideas that are cheap and
free do we have any ideas i have a few
eduardo any any thoughts for for lynn
um
donorschoose is a terrific platform to
socialize the potential needs you have
and they attract donors from
all over the country to support uh local
issues and local uh efforts um and then
sal i mean happy for you to add up
more
yeah yeah and
and i could just give you samples you
know we could go through the entire
sixth grade curriculum and you know some
of the things i'm not sure exactly on
the sixth grade standards but these are
the exa you know the kitchen chemistry
you can do a lot tonight so i encourage
any teachers to do web searches for just
kitchen chemistry obviously you can do
acid-base work do vinegar baking soda uh
you can do i've just made a whole series
of videos on distillation uh which i
think you can create
ad-hoc distillation setups at home uh
where maybe you want to distill water
separate you know pure water from salt
water or distill a mixture of um you
know whatever is in there
whatever's in their kitchen uh i i think
these things can be done with the stove
a pot and some contraptions maybe made
out of plastic and cardboard that you
know you cut up uh so you know physics
types things uh
if kids have springs if they have you
know honestly just a ball and a
stopwatch go outside say why you know
how high is something going based on how
long it's in the air
measuring air resistant so there's a lot
that can be done i highly recommend up
things you know home science or kitchen
chemistry type projects um to see to see
what's what's available
so
eduardo you know we've talked a lot
about kids entering careers in science
but we have a lot of young people who
watch this and one thing i always try to
ask as many guests as possible because
there's no major in college to do what
you do i mean there's not a lot of
majors to do exactly what a lot of folks
do but i think people when i was young
and i would see an eduardo settlin who
runs a foundation i was like how do you
end up there uh what's the background so
i'd love to folks a little bit to learn
about your personal journey
how did you end up as the president of
the amgen foundation sure sure so uh you
know i'm i'm i was born and raised in
brazil in a city called bella horizonte
it's up in the mountains it's not on the
coast so people think brazil they think
the beaches no that's not where where i
grew up
um
and it was very clear
uh to me that as i went through through
my education mostly in bello uh but also
had the opportunity to spend almost two
years in canada my dad's a professor and
went to continue his studies there it
helped me learn the english that i can
speak uh quite fluently as my my second
language
but i think back to you know the pursuit
of the college degree for me it was very
clear that that was the path to achieve
uh my independence and uh i
i say you know my dad's family came to
brazil from poland running away at the
time of the second world war that the
the jewish ethic
of
uh study hard
really over preparing uh was very
important for me uh learning as much as
i could at any point in time
the other side of that that you know
gets to the
to this moment where i'm living now is
so we have preparation on one side i had
inspiration on the other you know my mom
uh is from a small town in about four
hours from bello
it's called manual
which means big river in the local
indigenous language there called tupi
and large family you know she's one of
10 kids
and
my grandmother was
such a strong force in my life around
showing uh how much it is critical for
us to do for our neighbors how much is
important to engage with our community
and with my mom the sense of dreaming
you know what's possible how do you
achieve your dreams so
my journey in what i'll tell you about
how that evolved from the college degree
is really the mix of that preparation
and the inspiration very lucky to have
had both
um when i finished college i joined
general electric uh i did what's called
the finance management program it's a
two-year rotational program i did a year
and a half in brazil and then was very
lucky to be invited to come to the
united states for a six-month assignment
in a city called erie northwest
pennsylvania
uh working in finance uh
people typically uh don't we don't even
think about local i was in the
locomotive factory you know in the best
year ge made a thousand locomotives
think about that 20 a week that was my
introduction to what corporate america
can really do in the power to uh to to
bring progress uh
to
across our society
um
after
being a trainee i did a job in
systems and finance finance people
thought i was is information systems
information systems people thought
i was financed
did a job there had a very fancy title
called e-finance six sigma black belt
that's probably the coolest title of
lowest
i've ever had
and then a colleague uh told me about an
opportunity to come to amgen so come
across the country uh nice weather uh
and really a a promise of an industry
this amazing was a company's about seven
billion dollar revenues for about 25
today it's a huge opportunity for growth
and the job was to be an internal uh
consultant i came to that for about a
year and a half and then um hit a bit of
a snag in in my life in the sense of i
had just applied to join to start an mba
uh and was accepted to it but i didn't
feel that the work i was doing was
meaningful enough i felt listen it's
just my wife and i here in the united
states i need to do something that i
truly believe in and very fortuitous
timing the person who was running the mj
foundation then was building up a team
uh i was extremely lucky that she gave
me a shot and brought me into her team
i think about you know those five years
at the ge and at amgen they were
absolutely critical to make me eligible
to be considered for that role but that
only got me into the door the question
then was performance to succeed in the
new uh in the new bath
you know you talk about a company like
camgen we're about 20 22 000 staff
around the world the entire amazon
foundation team were about five people
so it's a small team
so what what really ensued in the many
coming years i've been at amg now for 17
is the steepest learning curve i could
ever have imagined the focus on all the
years i had invested in finance
colleagues that invested in pedagogical
skills and how do you
make the best possible science education
reality so i am a very studious person
i've been learning a lot and have the
privilege and the honor to work with
amazing people in my team and across the
enterprise
towards this really mission driven work
to help patients and through the
foundation to help the next generation
of of innovators so it's a long-winded
way to go but i think it's a way of
saying for me that what the the what i
do is as important as the why i do my
child
no that's fascinating actually you know
we've known each other for several years
now i didn't know all of uh that that
background and it is fascinating because
you know it's definitely if i were to
sample you at any point you know when
you're right out of college i don't
think you would have predicted where you
would have ended up but it sounded like
you had a nice
balance between you know the business
sense the finance side of things but
also the technical side whether it's you
know information sciences or the the
science side from your point of view
what do you think were the traits that
you brought to the table that you either
developed or maybe were just kind of a
mindset you brought
that allowed you to
succeed in these pretty diverse roles
that you've had over your career
hard work
determination
uh being a very studious person and
realizing what being willing to say i
don't know and doing the study and being
very curious
uh to continue uh learning more
luck i think luck is the kind of thing
that is underappreciated in our society
that's so worried about meritocracy
opportunities came to me in a time when
i could take advantage of them
but i'll say that you know if if i had
charted out a path to say i want to
become the president of the mg
foundation i don't know if the steps i
took would have been the same uh i i
think the sense of at each step of my
career i gave all i had i've always been
an
all-in kind of of person to really focus
and do the absolutely best that i could
and then so what i would say is that
those first five years in the in ge and
the beginning at amgen that the hard
the hard skills the focus on finance the
the ability so i worked in accounting i
worked in financial planning and
analysis
i worked in process improvements uh
within the financial organization so
at that point i was on a path to become
a finance professional and that was a
that was what i thought was possible
then even the the image of maybe there
is
something like a philanthropic
foundation that might be engaged in the
future
it only came much later about you know
the five years uh uh of experience that
i had um
i i would also add uh the sense of
um
the opportunities that come to us at
different points in our life are
sometimes it's harder to it's very hard
to realize what of of all the things
you're doing which ones are they going
to be the ones that are going to be
opening more doors or the ones that will
close stores
so um the more you can
apply yourself in paths that keep as
many doors open
i think uh the better uh the the the
the blend for me that i think was
instrumental in going into the
philanthropic space was the human side
of of of things you know you talk about
you know hard skills and soft skills uh
you talk about the importance you know
we're so uh focused on investing in stem
but the humanities have a huge role to
play here of course you know the the the
teacher who asked the question you know
that teacher has
a lot of different challenges in her
hand she has a curriculum to follow she
has
a lot of expectations around what her
students will uh leave the class
learning but she also has the human side
of of talking to those students who are
you know sixth grade that's uh
the same as my oldest daughter these
kids who you know going back to school
in all virtual space and uh their how
they feel about the friendships that
they are not making
how much do they really know the kid
across
the screen is that going to be a real
long-term friend or not so i i think
that as i think about young students in
in paving their paths forward
i think my best advice is to nurture
both your mind and your heart
the if if you uh there are great
resources around applying to college uh
there are great resources around
financing the college experience uh
google has just come up with some new
credentialing uh courses so even though
the world of higher education is rapidly
evolving
my sense is
follow
your dreams but not in the in the
platitude if you can do anything you put
your mind to because i think that that's
often a very unfair thing that is said
to young students we all face
constraints we all face limitations but
take advantage of the resources that are
available to you and style i think this
is a place where you know the
relationship that the foundation
developed with khan academy is critical
what drove you to start the khan academy
and
you know i read your letter to yourself
10 years ago when you had no idea how
big this thing was going to get
and to think about it now where you have
learners across the entire world
saying
irrespective of my family condition
if
i have access to the internet i have
access to a
world-class education for free
and i think that
that holds so much promise and for kids
today that's a resource that's available
that wasn't available when i was a kid
so again those different doors that
become available
and take advantage of free resources you
know we've also started something with
harvard called lab exchange which you
know is a partnership with khan academy
as well where they are creating a lot of
uh uh like a virtual laboratory and ways
for teachers to develop and bring their
own curriculum
technology is moving i think in a not
only in a fast way but in a way now that
is empowering the learning it's not tech
for tech's sake and that's right that's
the other part of what i love about your
world
it's about learning i don't care how
fancy the technology is and 3d goggles
and all of that that's all secondary the
important thing is that the student
learns and i'll close this piece with
you know comment earlier today my
youngest daughter uh you know she she is
in third grade and
her teacher mrs arnot is really a big
fan of khan academy and she's been doing
a lot of it so she came in and said well
you know yesterday i leveled down four
skills but today i've leveled up 12
skills
that opportunity where she sees
you know that she over struggling and
over investing her time she can overcome
and she can learn the content that the
teacher expects her to is the kind of
dynamic that is brand new so now she is
able to realize that yes i have a full
understanding of that content thanks to
sao khan
oh no i always love hearing stories like
that maybe one last question from
youtube flora star says what is amgen's
future plan to support students and i'll
i'll expand that question a little bit
you know eduardo if we're fast forward
10 years 20 years into the future uh
what do you hope to be the legacy of
your work and the foundation
so um i stand in the shoulder of giants
who really took a tiny foundation and
said hey
maybe it is possible to level the
playing field for learners around
uh where we
around the world
through hands-on learning
i hope my legacy is that i'm really able
to work with our amazing board of
directors who challenges me and my team
on a regular basis as well as our ceo to
say
have we done enough
how do we reach everyone that might be
interested in how to create the
opportunities for everyone to live up to
their potential
um i'm very hopeful that i'm able to
look back and you know see khan academy
uh much larger than it already is
uh to see the lab exchange platform
evolving and that students are able to
connect the world of their classroom
with the world of work and that we're
more effective at kind of connecting
those two so that
learning happens of course as you're
going through
the beginnings of your career but even
after you're on a full-time job you know
technology is here to stay and changings
are ever uh
present
how do you upskill yourself if you are a
50 year old
individual who just lost his or her job
and now you're thinking about you know
how do you continue providing for your
family there are resources such as khan
academy that provide
a specific knowledge around subjects and
how do we invent resources to equip
individuals to build upon what they
already know what they already do with
what complements them to do what is
needed from a work perspective today so
my senses were just beginning
our company has huge ambition as to how
we can go about serving patients
and that that means that citizens are
better informed that citizens are better
able to ask questions when they go to
the doctor and say
clinical trials you know if you get to
the end of
a standard of care for a cancer patient
um what happens then the only
opportunity you have is our clinical
trials
seventy percent of americans are
willing to participate in the clinical
trial yet one less than one in 20
patients are part of a cancer clinical
trial if you look at african-american
population 13 of our of of the us
population 5 of trial participants
latinos uh our latinx better said uh uh
one or two two percent of of
participants so
we live sal in a moment where all
everything we do through the foundation
and the possibilities of becoming
literate in navigating the world we all
live in
connects directly with the ability to
succeed in this environment
learning
ongoing asking good questions and
avoiding i carry this magazine with me
the war on science climate change does
not exist evolution never happened the
moon landing was fake how is it possible
that
questions like that are asked today when
we carry supercomputers in our pockets
when we can harness the immune system to
fight cancer
i
look forward and say in partnership such
as what amgen foundation and all of your
other funders have with you
sal that we can start creating a world
that is fair and that every student has
access to the opportunities that they
deserve
well uh i i look forward to going on an
adventure with all of with you because i
couldn't agree more that
uh the world more than ever needs this
and if we're able to do it we can do so
much for for humanity eduardo thank you
so much for uh one all you know sharing
your time with us today but also this
partnership uh that we've had for many
years and hopefully will empower many
tens of millions of of folks families
teachers and students uh over the
decades to come thank you
thank you sal really appreciate the
opportunity and look forward to
continuing our journey
well thanks everyone for for joining as
always a really interesting conversation
about the importance of science and the
importance that corporations and
corporate foundations can have in
helping empower folks obviously helping
us do the work we do but well well
beyond that i i want to remind everyone
for tomorrow's a homeroom it's going to
be at 12 30
it's going to be with chancellor robert
jones of the university of illinois
urbana-champaign and that's going to be
really interesting because they are i
would say more proactive about
testing and contact tracing on
around kovid than as any university that
i'm aware of and maybe anywhere in the
in the country right now
and so it's going to be a really
interesting conversation about this
intersection between keeping the virus
from spreading on a campus where kids
are there and trying to get back to
school as normal they've actually
developed their own tests it's going to
be a really interesting conversation 30
minutes later than our normal time so i
look forward to seeing everyone then
you